pie ix à what's your name j'ai créé un
robot qui s'appelle sarah sochaux ou r
global system et sarah a la
particularité de pouvoir créer un lien
intime un lien personnel avec ses
utilisateurs est leur pose des questions
sur eux-mêmes elle s'intéresse à leurs
intérêts elle elle sourit et elle fait
tout ce qu'il faut pour avoir une
confiance pour établir une confiance
entre elle et son utilisateur
il sait pas moyen de cette confiance qui
s'installe que elle arrive à mieux
accomplir ses tâches par exemple de vous
faire des recommandations de films de
vous présenter aux gens qui pourraient
vous intéresser
etc